oh my god
my shoulders have been tense for the
last 25 minutes
citizens of the reject nation we are
here to watch house of the dragon
episode 4 today
i am loving this show so much how about
you john i am too enthralled i would say
it's probably my favorite thing on tv at
the moment yeah yeah that's an awesome
good assessment i might be inclined to
agree with you this is a good subjective
assessment
anyway guys if you can leave a like i
know you can please go ahead and do that
i mean a lot also subscribe and click
the notification bell get notified when
our reaction for the next episode of
house of the dragon is up here on this
channel as always following through
action watch alongs where you sync up
with your own copy of house of the
dragon for our super sexy rejects at our
patreon page become a super sexy video
today to check out everything we gotta
offer over there exclusively lastly the
team of prepper you guys rock thank you
for helping cut this down let's get to
it
[Music]
and though my seat may be less size
it is situated
mostly 46 years later
a hundred years into the future
did you think my great-grandmother is
beautiful as they say this
was half a century ago princess
yes it was
i think i remember 50 year old women
she wins the crowd over with humor
my princess
art is a bond that has long endured this
is lucas blackwood the grandson of my
grandsire aided the dragon in his war of
conquest i
the blackwoods truly turn the tide on
that one
your day shall be easy
and night safe
under my protection
protection the princess has a dragon you
dumb
i'm gonna like that one
yeah mary that guy over there
craven
we're leaving
oh i don't want to see this play out
yeah
send words to the harbour and have
captain austin ready to ship princess
in three days i would happily roll
myself back to king's
yeah man jokes don't get too far in
westeros
what's going on
are they being attacked damon coming to
visit oh [ __ ]
is he got his hair tied up
straight up cut that [ __ ] damn
add it to the chair
he's so freaking cool
you wear a crown
you also call yourself king
once we smash the trial key they name me
king of the narrow sea oh
boy but i know that there is only one
true king your grace
well played
[Music]
i wear this crown of crabs
upon my dragon chair
hug
[Applause]
best goddamn reality tv i've seen in a
while
so great at playing up the tension of
all their interactions
you only want my name in my valyrian
blood for their offspring
i think it's rather romantic
how romantic it must be to get
imprisoned in a castle in me to squeeze
out to ass
it's nice to see them
kind of bonding again i am glad you are
home
i find i have
a few friends baby
i've missed you too
is said to have engaged in negotiations
with the sea lord of braavos he plans to
wed his daughter lena to the sea lord's
son if house valerian entered into an
alliance with the free cities
we would have to seek our own
marriage pact
oh
god
you better get on it man
find the d
game of d
you know just beat lord corliss down
there and marry him instead
[Music]
wow
[Music]
she's like princess jasmine
[Music]
[Music]
do an assassin's creed jump
[Applause]
this is her first time getting to really
see what it's like at night yeah i bet
[Music]
he called me
he called me boy
our good king
names his daughter
a girl
his heir
oh my god have them all executed do many
of the
focus
that as small
everyone should be the heir
yeah
their wants are of no consequence
you take care boy
next time you might not be so lucky
enjoy that did you
who knows what our next takes freedom
i love it when they get along
come
pardon me your grace
the king has requested your presence
oh
i think i want to start making another
heir what is this place
it's where people come to take what they
want
holy christ
there is some stuff going on
[Music]
oh my god
oh
my god wow
[Music]
i feel so conflicted
this
squeamish sin of sexes
so i'm so uncomfortable
it's been a long time since i've had
this array of feelings to deal with
during the show
jesse you
just my pride i shall allow the lord
commander
my helmet
oh no she's got a taste of the fun
wow
bring back that dark messed up drumming
music
the love of god
[Music]
interesting correlation it's like they
have one of sexual depravity and now
one that actually seems sweet right
after almost doing it with their uncle
well yeah i'm like
backed up against a wall versus
truly being together
yeah dude don't reject her it's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity this is
such a process to get to
get to the action
we do wear a lot of layers don't we
i like these like very realistic giggles
she has
she's so great
like in every
type of moment
now go wait outside my door
now stand watch the rest of the night is
she gonna get pregnant with his kid i
wouldn't put it past him
the master brings word from the white
worm
ah crap
god damn it i knew it
oh no
[Music]
come
that's great news for you otto
i have um
discomforting news i thought it best
shared discreetly before the council
convenes i [ __ ] the sea stake
i'm afraid it concerns the princess my
king
the flesh snake the princess was spied
last evening
beyond the walls of the keep
in a pleasure house
like that take his hand so uncomfortable
with her uncle
they were engaged in
unbecoming of a maiden
of a princess
my kids saw that what must i say to you
you enter my bed chamber accusing my
daughter of something
i speak it
plainly
[Laughter]
have this rumor manga brought before me
at once and i will take their eyes
the princess
creeping through the gates from king's
landing disguised as a page
during the hour of the owl oh my god was
this demon's plan the whole time yeah i
bet
do you wish to have your blood on the
iron throne so badly that you are
willing to destroy my own leave me
once
oh
that is pretty crazy
because otto they had that moment with
otto beforehand you see that
he really doesn't actually want to
communicate yeah
like as much as you want to smack him i
do kind of feel bad
just bring damon and uh her in the same
room
talk it out
on the mori show
you are not the father
princess i have a message from the queen
my shoulders have been tense for the
last 25 minutes
your father accused me of something was
i drank wine if the castle after dark
think you [ __ ] damn it in a pleasure
house this
is a vile accusation you targaryens do
have queer customs
and damon certainly knows no limit
allison
your grace sister you must know i would
oh my god
yay
i used to see her like this
who made these claims to your father
i am the princess to
to question my virtue is an act of
treason
that goddamn trees watching you
[Laughter]
the old gods man david sank into his
cups and
abandoned me for
some haul
[Music]
what's gonna happen
can't be the end of this
i swear this to you upon the memory of
my mother
it was foolish of you to place yourself
in a position where your virtue could
even come into question
says okay
[Laughter]
a little bit of pot and kettle action
there
whatever
the king demands an audience
take your hands off
oh my god thank god he's hungover
you better have a good matching story
he's still drunk
oh i hope the stories line up i feel
like i'm watching an alex garland movie
i know
[Laughter]
so
twisted [ __ ] up humanity
when we were near his age we way through
most of the brothels on the street of
silk we were young man she is just a
girl
your niece there is a woman grown better
first experience be with me than somehow
you have ruined her what lord will wed
her now in this condition because some
lord thinks
you are the dragon your word is truth
and law
i have spent a lifetime defending you
but your heart is even blacker than i
thought
i should disinherit her
if i already did you be done with it
waiter to me
well
go back to the veil damon
to your lawful wife
or don't
matters not to me
as long as you are gone from my side for
good it's crazy there's like no violence
in this episode
[Laughter]
you believe he lied how often does he
speak the pure truth
how does confessing to such things serve
him
by reducing you
and your heir
monero is not innocent
only because damon tried to corrupt her
damon renero she had the blood of the
dragon she swore to me that she remains
a maiden
and i believe her
oh please don't be pregnant
nine months later
from my
blood come the prince that was promised
and his will be the song of ice and fire
your courtship is at an end
you will wed celeno valarion
and you will do so without protest
the son of the sea snake
so i can be a remedy for your political
headaches you are my political headaches
[Laughter]
like a mediator in here
and what will you do about the vulture
who perches upon your throne
what vulture
your hands yeah
he wants aegon to be named er
and he will stop at nothing to see it
done
including spying on me to bring about my
ruin i will do my duties here
and with soleno
but you must first do yours as king
oh
how long did it take you to choose
yourself over your king
your grace
will never recover from emma's death
but alison
she was a calculated distraction
the queen loves you
i made sure of it
the crowd in the realm
both of you are dead can never be repaid
but i could no longer trust your
judgment
that's crazy he told the truth and what
that's so insane
all the [ __ ] manipulation this guy
did it was the truth about
that's how the karma comes around
that is nuts the ultimate irony i took
great care in its preparation
if not brewed properly it can either
prove ineffective or else
beautifully
i'm sorry what is that it's like a day
after pill tea princess
from the king
it will rid you of any unwanted
consequences
oh yeah you haven't had the talk
that must be very painful
[Music]
oh my god
i did
it's a great shot to leave off on too
because like i wouldn't trust that but
also
probably a good idea
it was not fun that was
that was uncomfortable
it was like a yeah it was like
some kind of action movie but instead of
fights just it's all discomfort and
conflicting views
okay
yeah all right so
this show is awesome this is a terrific
uh piece of television yeah like
we're back goddamn houses this is bold
that's
it's like the characters are it's i love
how they're doing the time jumps because
it's not just so plot driven it's so
cute it's like
so wildly character driven you just
watch out how these people just change
over time and
you just got such different sides of
everyone it
i felt like so many different directors
influences in this like tonal wise like
there were parts of it that reminded me
of alex garland who did stuff like ex
machina annihilation
and then uh there are elements of it
that also kind of remind me of ari astor
who films like hereditary and mitsumar
and uh i would also say like i did a
tinge of lars von trier yeah
it's just that sexual twistedness yeah
yeah
where
you know like i know the
the
the the religion and deities that these
guys worship is not like christianity
but like we grew up catholic we're like
sexual things and lust are very
very much they're frowned upon they're
not looking they're not look kindly upon
just the thoughts
and it it was
it was a fascinating look at it we're
like game of thrones it's kind of just
like the world of it just inhabits it
you know and then
i did think it was actually kind of
interesting that when they did go to the
brothel and that's like the
the cd underbelly of this world that was
just so much people just given in to
their
their desires given into their their
bodily wants and such ultimate hedonism
and how it was captured in like a dark
cringey way well yeah it feels like
you're watching like a like a witch
movie or something like that because
yeah it's like all these long shots
robert eggers in here too yeah cause
you're looking through fire and
everything's lit by fire so you have
that sort of dancing strobing but also
very dim light just disassociates you
with shadowy deeds and yeah you're going
through these narrow winding streets and
in through corridors and you're watching
a show and then you're in the pleasure
house and yeah like it feels very carnal
it's so much of uh yeah it's a good word
for it carnal um it so much of it seemed
to be dealing with uh
the themes of when our
desires have great consequences
yeah
you know because so much of the time you
know especially with a character like
renera a lot of these characters too you
know
it's
not only the consequences but how our
how our desires of what we want to
conflict so much with the reality of
what we have
and how that makes us feel yeah you know
like when it is cutting back and forth
between like
this
this lustful situation because they
didn't actually like go all the way
right
if i read that scene correctly
yeah yeah they didn't yeah that's why
she still needed more yeah
yeah exactly yeah they didn't go all the
way so
they went a further they went enough
yeah they went enough
like oh my god he definitely broke some
firsts
yeah
uh so they went they went enough but um
because like when they're cutting to
there and then you're even cutting to
alison and there's so much about you
know how
allison is serving her role
and she's just like surrendering her
body you should be very careful my words
here because youtube sucks
um like surrendering her body
uh to the situation and you see that she
is just not about it no no not there
yeah but it's it's it's what she she has
to do and it's like she's a young woman
and i'm sure she would probably desire
some hot young stud
but this is what she has to do
and then you're watching how
you know like allison is doing what she
has to do clearly not happy
and then you watch renera giving in to
some desires
and she's enjoying it right yeah it's
like a
if it's like i know the actress milli
alcock is is not a teenager
um but i i'm so used to her from being
like a teenager yeah i was like oh yeah
i have to like work my brain around it
like especially when she's doing certain
scenes that you know she's not a
teenager yeah she's she's like actually
in her 20s all right okay yeah my mind
has to kind of catch up a little bit
because i'm so used to seeing her in the
frame it's okay that discomfort is a
good thing it's a good thing yeah
yeah
yeah otherwise you're like i don't know
if i want to watch this yeah this seems
unethical
how is this on the most popular network
on television
yeah um
but yeah as she's giving her uh her
desires that how she suffers the
consequences for it or is allison you
know does it but either way it leads to
a life of
suppressing what we really want
and
being ultimately unhappy for it in the
service of duty and honor you know and
having
your autonomy in that side of your life
basically removed in the interests of
yeah your political uh
worth or you know yeah whatever you are
to the king and all that sort of other
stuff that takes hold
like it's funny that people don't dog on
this show so much for like being woke
because like so much of this is about
and they say it multiple times like she
was a young man no one would care like
she could go out and do whatever she
wants you know in the pleasure house or
with anybody with a family member
whoever but because you're a woman and
in the position you are yeah it's like
people are gunning for you and you can't
live
you know you can't get out there and
live
no
i mean
maybe they don't
gun for being woke because of uh the
fact that she's just a super well
written character and the world didn't
happen since mainly a lot of men
you know
and so yeah i think that
you know what we saw renera go through
in this episode was
so fascinating like when she started uh
like just a r i i i just admire the
writing so much like when she's talking
to allison and she gets into
like she's been caught mowed
but she has to lie her way out of it
she's such calling her like you're grace
sister you know saying things i'm like
she doesn't she doesn't talk like this
man
that's not a toxin
she doesn't resort to this
you only like just started to mend this
bridge
just getting desperate
and
and then watching her lie
um
with such conviction
is not something that in the past like
you feel like you've gotten to know
these people remarkably well
the time jumps yeah despite the time
justice fight that's only been four
episodes that you feel like you really
know these people
which is such a testament to the show
so to see her lie
is like oh i'm not
i'm not you that's not the rinner i know
i know her for being the one who says
the uncomfortable truths all the time
and stands up for what she really wants
thanks you know so to see her be
put in that position
and um
uh almost like borderline
submissive to a situation
it's
i gotta i don't know i gotta process
this episode
i i don't wanna just repeat the word
uncomfortable kind of aches you know
it's a little bit of an achy feeling i'm
noticing in my heart like it's sort of
like twisting it
well yeah because there's so much
they have a great i think blend of
you know you're there for part of it you
see you know this sort of i don't know
it comes from multiple perspectives
because you know as you're i love the
intercutting
and the contrast they draw in that scene
because at first i was like oh that's
kind of random we just cut back to
allison but then the more times they do
that you you see yeah that contrast and
it's like you're there and in parts with
uh renera you know some of you is like
yeah get out there like you know go see
the city like you know you you live this
life concerned with things inside the
walls of you know your your
your castle home but like really go see
what life is like and yeah you know you
just
go enjoy some earthly pleasures it's a
very human thing but then to then
realize that like okay
a
it's happening with her her uncle and
then b i don't know what if he actually
like they seem to have a real rapport
but then you're like well is he just
trying to use her to get
under viserys's skin and then you know
you have the bit where alison and
rhaenyra kind of break the ice again
after so long realizing that they're
both subject to this system and both
unhappy in various ways because of it
and then watching as that is effectively
kind of called into question and
destroyed and then you have like otto
hightower who we've come to this point
of being like i don't really like or
trust this guy i love watching
him and i love risa fonz's performance
and then this episode you have him in
arguably the most uh sympathetic and and
he's clearly acting or it would seem the
performance suggests he's acting out of
integrity at least in this isolated
moment so it takes all these things you
know about characters and all these ways
you feel about them and it really plays
on and
forces them in uncomfortable positions
and i feel like you know especially in
the puritanical
world of the united states you know
there's a certain amount of like shame
surrounded any
sexual conversation
uh and so to see that rightfully so
as dirty you don't be ashamed you're
going to hell
every sperm is sacred
um but like that's already such a kind
of angsty faculty of life and then you
dump all these politics and yeah the
warring perspectives and the idea of
like it doesn't really matter what the
truth is it just matters how people
perceive it and you get the whole thing
with the play and you already know this
mounting weight of like god the people
in my dad's council have their
perceptions of me and they don't want me
on the throne and it seems like the
common folk don't and yeah it just draws
this
really painful situation where yeah all
you want is relief and the characters
seem to express this longing for relief
especially renera like i'd love to be
just without the constraints of my duty
and and my mantle and these things that
have been thrust upon me and the episode
never gives you a moment to breathe
because yeah the whole time you are just
kind of
tense oh my shoulders started to hurt
yeah yeah yeah i had this like tension
just kicked right in
right by the sides of my neck yeah it
was just kicking in just so hard i'm
like i
i'm not enjoying this but i can't stop
watching yeah and it's weird because
it's like
and you get conflicted even in moments
like or i did where i like i love i love
the back and forth that milly alcock and
matt smith have and i love especially
when they're speaking uh it's old
valerian right uh when they're speaking
to each other in that way
and
during that sequence
i was like yeah you know
until they actually you know
turn toward each other in the pleasure
house you know you're like yeah i kind
of like it when they hang out they
should spend more time to get like you
kind of feel that rush of
you know freedom through that and i'm
like i like both these guys and i like
damon the most when he's hanging with
raniere and then yeah it twists it
in
in a place we've been in game of thrones
you know lower before but yeah into
something that is just so uncomfortable
and strange and and
you know he says that thing about like
well you know why not me why not
somebody who she knows and who is you
know of royal blood and you're like i
guess for the time that's an argument
but ugh like
yeah it just it it
i think it plays on the fundamental
thing that we've all been through of you
sneak out you get some fun in you
experience a little bit of the world
that's hitherto been kind of kept from
you
and there is that russian catharsis but
also the immediate plunge back into
consequences as you know the people who
are above you or who see
more of the picture than you do or have
access to more of the picture than you
do then come and you know
uh reprimand and or shame you for
whatever it is and then you you know
multiply that by all the crazy state
craft iron throne circumstances and
politics and stuff like that that's all
it is that's the game of thrones right
there yeah it's a fascinating
emotional interplay this episode
good for uh good for kristen though
good for sir kristin
this is like the the one guy
who's kind of all right
well yeah i mean i think that's why they
i think they do a good job at flushing
that out that it's
because it could have it could have just
been that that feeling of exploring the
sexual desires is a dark
dark thing but it it shows uh something
kind of sweet and beautiful yeah between
the two of them something that felt like
they really are connected and there is a
genuine romance between them and i think
the show's done a good job on building
up both yeah this is stuff that's been
percolating throughout the years for
these characters us a few episodes but
years for them right from the first
moment that
you see in that first episode of matt
smith puts the necklace around rain era
it was like is there some type of thing
yeah i don't know i can't tell them
maybe um i suppose so and well now you
look back and you're like maybe yeah and
then they're kind of and they bring it
back at the beginning with the necklace
too and it's so much about
giving i feel like that's probably what
damon wanted was to
put up the card out there of let me
marry her like it's already gone to this
point but then he wasn't even going all
the way there so he even felt conflicted
about it as well like he kept pulling
away and at first i thought it was just
some like act of like come get me yeah
and then it wasn't and he just straight
up abandoned her yeah
and you could tell that he was in his
own head about the whole thing too like
i don't really know what damon's purpose
for returning is that's part of the
complexity of his character is
that tug and pull of
being and that's what's so great about
all these characters is there's so many
different things of what they all no
one's one note he he wants more he wants
power but he also wants connection he
also wants family
with the with the people he's also
combative with you know there's so many
things happening i think going off of
where the three episodes prior were
building what i love about it is
it seemed like the crumble would happen
externally from a war or some [ __ ] like
that
but really what's causing everything to
crumble is all within the castle and all
within the family family melodrama all
the people who are living in the
hightower you know those are all that's
where everything
is starting to
um it's it like forming like like this
like a virus of insidious feelings just
taking over and then seeping through
everyone because everyone has desires
and everyone has
wants and needs and and they all have a
certain direction they want to take so
yeah it's kind of cool watching like
rainer being sort of
like having to accept the positions he's
in and then willing to go through with
the marriage but
you know feeling that need to also
protect her reputation
as well uh it it was a really really
like messed up episode yeah i loved it
yeah
i i loved it i loved it i love the
uncomfortableness because when they are
going through the city i'm like oh it's
kind of like a jasmine thing and then
when they they're seeing the play i'm
like oh it must be about just trying to
convince aegon to get you know like hey
you're probably better off with aegon
taking the throne you know i i thought
that's where the conversation was headed
was them debating about it
i didn't think it was going into this
other
this this very different direction and
uh with otto was that was great that was
that was excellent like they know how to
mess with you because you've kind of
wanted him to get exposed
and
he he did his job the way he was
supposed to well that's the thing too is
i think that contributes to that harsh
feeling the episode gives you as you're
like as much as you want him to be
exposed it still pangs when you're like
ah but this isn't actually in this
isolated situation the right thing isn't
happening for everybody well he wasn't
fired from being the hand
for
lying yeah
it was because of the thing raynera put
out there yeah you waited so long right
now
you knew yeah you knew this whole time
and then she was waiting to dish that
out
save her ass
yeah i'm like you pulled the card at the
right time what's the other thing i
think they're really good at and and
they're good at drawing
characters in a way where you can
no one is ever 100
one thing and that's makes for
compelling drama and mystery but they're
good at generally kind of depicting the
characters who are calculating and who
have very long-term view versus
characters who like like i i love damon
partly because you always have to wonder
like i don't know if he really does have
an in advance plan half the time i feel
like he just does stuff
on compulsion and because he is so
minded towards these things obviously
they have political cunning and
ramifications to them but yeah they're
good at drawing those different
boundaries between yeah the very
conniving characters versus the just
super impulsive characters and i feel
like you can kind of see that
intersection
with rhaenyra especially well i think
also with viserys that speech that he
gave to otto at the end it seemed like
it was a thing that he always kind of
knew
sure you know you probably
he
he's
a lot of these people tend to go into
denial about [ __ ] and
they have to really suck it up in order
especially for king like yeah for
viserys who's
constantly like i'm just
trying not to get everyone killed just
trying to keep everyone happy okay
trying to keep things
not everyone protesting all the time
like like i know everyone's
self-interested all right i get it like
i think we could do i sympathize for the
guy
a lot of the ways you know
um because he's a great character
there's so many people just getting used
and tossed around and abused like alison
used the pla he she played the king but
she was also being kind of like [ __ ]
out by her father you know
and
so in that moment of when when they're
having
their intermingling
at night i'm like well you know they're
married and i know she's not into she's
not doing anything
bad right now it's uncomfortable
to watch because she so doesn't just do
it in because she has to yeah um but you
know he was under the impression too
that
she was actually like really in love
with him and stuff and then
it's just ever you're just we're
watching this viserys guy just get
[ __ ] so hurt because you can tell
there's so much love in this guy's heart
like oh my wife doesn't really love me
she was just using me and after about
the wife who really did love me died in
a terrible tragic death where my son
died my own daughter i'm trying to keep
this [ __ ] in order now she's banging my
brother
this is so all over the place and he's
just you we're watching this dude just
deteriorating yeah
not only that but my daughter refuses to
let me help her because he seems still
like
you know committed to having her be the
heir and it's like oh you're not helping
me man
yeah whoa he's he's a great character
too like like props to patty considine
because
i feel like it would be easy to make a
character like this
feel just like a dope but uh especially
for he's aware of a lot yeah yeah yeah
and i feel like we've had kings
similar at least briefly in other game
of thrones seasons where you're like ah
yeah this guy's not made for this world
at all um and and viserys while there is
a lot about him where i'm like yeah i
mean you're not gonna be the most sung
about
targaryen king like yeah the the
complexity with which they draw his
pitfalls as a character versus the
moments of strength i think are really
compelling and
everybody
testament to the casting everybody and
him as well
like there's so much in the faces and so
much in the performances along with the
great writing that like yeah i just
can't take my eyes off of him and rinero
is going to be marrying um
the son
of
poreless i believe who is the that is
the husband of what not it's not written
here over here
uranus or something like that
because i've been wondering where she's
been and and having them have scenes
together again it's like
oh damn them getting married
it just it shows
like venera is not
winning that argument that she was
having audrey's yeah yeah clearly
yeah oh well and i mean imagine what
they're gonna have to talk about when
she gets there
uh yeah i love it it's uh it's so messed
up
i enjoy it so much
rich it's dark but rich it's like a it's
like a it's like a 97
dark chocolate because like the first
three episodes were like
there were some real like horror
especially in the first episode it's
truly horrific birthing scene
um
but for the most part the show has been
like
dark messed up but fun
yeah and this is the crab feeder stuff
yeah
so entertaining
and and this one this episode was so
dread heavy yeah and so much of a of a
build in in a way that felt more play
like like a play
yeah and then um
you know some extravagant expensive tv
show
it was very
very very beyond intimate
and not indulgent in because sometimes
you know what these shows are like when
you know today we need to do the fun
stuff and then hear them like that's
really sort of a twisted purpose this
time yeah real twisted purpose oh yeah
and i mean
that was a funny thing they said before
the season like we're not going to do as
many gratuitous
uh lovemaking scenes and this episode
certainly has a lot of flesh on display
but it does feel more like it is there
for a direct purpose than just being
like we're hbo'd we can
uh
well yeah i mean i think i think it just
finally clicked with me now way late in
this conversation of
it it does emit that feeling of
like
you know if if people are participating
in such group activities there's nothing
technically wrong with that uh it's it's
really the fact that
through her perspective you know through
the position she's in it's wrong for her
to be there yeah you know
um and it's so far beyond anything that
she's
usually subject to like i can't say no
to this and this is not gonna lead to
something good yeah so
yeah i liked it it felt like threatening
one two like
really great use of both music and sound
design because especially during that
sequence where they're out in the city
and they're headed towards the pleasure
house there's that there's that passage
where the music even gives way to just
this like
unsettling harsh ringing tone that just
gets louder and louder and louder as
this is all happening and and that
really kind of struck me on like a
i don't know deep down sort of
primordial level and it does feel like
that kind of
haze that comes on when you are in a
risky situation like that and you are
kind of losing innocence and you are
sort of
in between the margins of acceptability
and danger and all sorts of stuff like
it it really
as much as like what's on the page and
what is acted is really effective
they're also really good at transporting
you in a tonal sensory way
without yeah needing to be like
hey you know like this episode is so
human in so many ways and that's partly
what i think makes it feel so harsh and
so conflicting
because it is all
in there you don't need a dragon or a or
a zombie creature or a big battle or
something you know to hit that you know
you just need the real margins of
humanity and then multiply it by the
time and place that we're in but yeah
yeah
all right guys well
um what'd you think of the episode leave
your thoughts down below uh
subscribe and
leave a like and he will end this with a
patreon
anisa oliva niece
we are typing in what your name means oh
here we go here we go
oh my god this is too long yeah man he
wants to read all that
novel about anissa all right thanks for
being here
we love you
all right here we go cool anisa
beautiful girl true
contest
sometimes crazy but as but fun as hell
to be around true
so true one time i saw her rob a bunch
of homeless children yeah they had it
coming admittedly it was like what are
you doing but surprisingly led to a lot
of laughter it was crazy but it was fun
as hell loves attention she vlogged the
whole thing you can look it up it's
amazing selling copies surprisingly
sounds offensive
but actually really funny you got to see
it rides the line
um shy at times oh yeah totally i mean
approaching those homeless kids took it
it takes a little bit occurred it's like
an hour yeah it's not easy talking to
homeless kids no you know relate to the
homeless kids near like i just don't
understand like what that is
very sweet but can be mean when she has
to be yeah like when she's shaking down
homeless kids
yeah i mean but you know mean when she
has to be yeah and frankly you gotta do
it for the abuse incredibly sexy oh yeah
oh my god yeah those homeless kids were
thirsting loyal and uh intelligent her
body is to die for so many of them broke
puberty that day yeah she is
bootylicious oh dude
dude the boot wow the scoot the
hemisphere it
encompasses yeah is so just
perfect circumference goes through the
imagine lines
and you put the pencil in the paper
wormhole dude flat circle every guy
seems to be drawing her and not just
because of her amazing ass ets
she's more than just her butt that's for
sure man true she's got a bit of a brain
but the butt is is a is a strong detail
she can be feisty oh yeah dude total
[ __ ] at times but man so hot
god anisa oh dude you you do be a feisty
you wanna be [ __ ] you can get away with
that anisa because you're so
bootylicious
but that's one of the many reasons why
you will love her because she's not
actually a [ __ ] yeah it's true because
she's easy to talk to she's easy to talk
to she's funny she's honest and has a
beautiful smile and a big heart again
huge ass
definitely someone you don't want to
lose that's true we have to lose that
ass we don't want a loser she's a tough
warrior woman who was also
hilarious
authentic
and just so
natural you know and ask for a better
friend than just so
natural so natural oh natural i'm just
like that's the word to describe no
preservatives natural no
process people are always like foods
natural in what way
i'm like you know what i mean yeah
natural 100 organic and then i was like
you need to elaborate more repeating the
word natural does not tell me more about
what a niece is natural at or in or
about
i'm like look here's how i would
describe it
natural natural it's in her nature and
frankly
that's why she had to step in and be at
those homeless kids because they just
kept asking too many questions yeah you
know yeah it just got in the way and she
just naturally stepped in and dealt with
it took care of those homeless kids man
that's right
those homeless kids who never really got
their due that day into the ass
thanks anisa oh give me bread shut up i
don't have bread i think i just walk
around with bread on me yeah what do you
think this is this is oliver twist right
now
what what century are we in
someone's gonna comment i'm a homeless
kid that's offensive
like what you're doing with the phone
you're homeless dude what are you at the
library right now what's going on your
youtube account you're smarter than this
you should you should be out there
making a living if you're capable of
this
[Music]